hello everyone welcome back to the
channel today we are going to be talking
about distributed consensus now this is
only consensus in the computer term if I
could actually solve consensus my
parents wouldn't be divorced but
nonetheless here we are today so let's
get into some content because I have to
leave the house soon
all right so as I previously mentioned
in the last video the entire point of
doing all of this is to basically build
linearizable storage and what
linearizable storage is going to allow
us to do is build applications on top of
that such as distributed locking or
service Discovery mechanisms obviously
we'll cover those in a later video so
the algorithm I'm actually going to be
talking about today is called raft and
what raft allows us to do is build a
distributed log why do we want a
distributed log because logs are ordered
hence they are linearizable and that is
extremely important for us so how does
raft actually work and I guess
additionally why am I not talking about
paxos or some other distributed
consensus algorithm well raft is just a
little bit simpler to teach hence why
it's popular and easier to understand so
doesn't that work out for all of us
bozos okay so how does raft actually
work from just like a very high level
perspective again we're building a
distributed log and what the log
actually contains is we have an
operation and and we have something
called a term number and we'll touch
into what the term number really
signifies and what it means a little bit
later in this video but the gist is that
we're going to have a leader
and the leader is asynchronously
replicating over to the follower notes
and keep in mind that this is
asynchronous replication so it is
possible for one follower to be behind
as you can see this log is not as up to
date as the one on the leader it's not
possible for all of the logs to be
behind as we'll talk about probably
mostly in the next video but yeah for
this video mainly I want to focus on one
of two steps of raft which is actually
picking which node is going to be the
leader because that in and of itself is
quite an interesting process and in
picking the leader we can kind of Ensure
a bunch of invariants about our system
that are going to be important when it
comes time to actually start making
rights
so let's look at raft leader election
and how does it work so basically our
raft leader which we can see right here
on the left of the screen has something
called an epoc number and in addition to
that we'll we'll touch more upon what
this Epoch number actually means but as
a result of just kind of how raft Works
we're going to be constantly sending
heartbeats or pings over to our
followers on some interval and basically
eventually you know if this guy decides
to go down one of our followers is going
to say hey I haven't received heartbeats
anymore it's time for me to complain
obviously we don't want them all
complaining at the same time because
then it's just going to be bad for our
system we're going to have a lot of
network traffic a bunch of other stuff
so let's say you know we randomize the
amount of time it takes for each
follower to complain this guy will
complain after 10 seconds this guy will
complain after five seconds
so obviously because the bottom node is
going to complain sooner than the top
one it is going to be the one that
ultimately proposes a new election it's
going to say hey I haven't heard from
the leader in a little bit so let's
start a new election and what about me
as the candidate so what this guy is
known as is the candidate
and as you can see because the epoch
number before of the previous leader was
28 this guy is going to say okay well I
am candidate for term 29. and so that is
going to be how the election actually
gets started so what happens during the
election let's scroll on to our next
screen here this one has a lot going on
so I'm going to try and show it all
properly so there are a few actual
possibilities of things that can happen
and I'm going to show them all off so
let's say this is the candidate right
here over on the top left
so the candidate is now going to propose
a term number 29 and let's say it's got
a log like so where it has two
operations and you can see the epochs
that those operations were written from
so let's say the message actually gets
to the previous leader right if the
previous leader receives message from a
potential candidate saying hey you're no
longer the leader well then the only
thing that that leader can do is say
shoot I guess I'm no longer the leader
so it's going to change its status to a
follower for term 29. another
possibility of what's going to happen is
that the node that receives this kind of
proposal
is just going to be a follower from a
previous Epoch and what that's now going
to do is even still as long as basically
the term number is going to be lower
than the one being proposed it's going
to increment its local term number to
the term number of The Proposal even
still it doesn't necessarily have to
vote for the candidate yet but it does
need to increment its number to that
term and we'll see why and then next
another possibility is that you know if
we go to a node with a higher term
number a greater than or equal to term
number than the one being proposed so in
this case it's a follower from term 29.
that implies that there was already a
leader for term 29 and if there was
already a leader for term 29 then we are
going to go ahead and say no to our
candidate over here so that is why we
have this no operation over here as you
can see we've already processed a write
during this term
and then finally another possibility is
that we reach out to a follower from
term 28 and the follower is going to say
oh okay well I can see there's a new
election going on let me change my term
number to turn 29 and because
your log here's the follower log right
down here here is the candidate log
because the candidate log is greater
than or equal to as updated as my local
log I am going to respond yes and it's
very simple basically if you have a term
number that was equal to the term number
being proposed or rather if you have a
term number that was lower locally than
the one being proposed and the log that
you have locally is either the same as
the one being proposed or it is less up
to date then you can go ahead and say I
will give you my vote otherwise you will
not give them your vote but you will
still of course update your term number
to the one being proposed if it's higher
than your local term number so a lot of
steps yeah but hopefully that generally
makes sense okay so what actually
happens when the candidate receives some
votes well if they hear yes from a
quorum
keep in mind from our leaderless
replication videos that means a majority
of notes it has won the election and it
can be a leader
so why does this system actually work
for you know kind of ensuring the
Integrity of our logs such that we can
make sure that we only have one leader
at once well for starters we obviously
cannot elect two leaders at the same
time because of quorums if we have three
nodes you know say I get these two votes
I can't also get these two votes because
there's overlap between them so a quorum
is not going to solve our issues there
in addition uh for number two old
leaders cannot come back due to this
fencing token slash Epoch number what is
a fencing token well the fact that we
have this Epoch number basically means
that if an older leader proposes a right
with a lower Epoch number than the
current term we know that it is an old
leader and it shouldn't be proposing
rights and then we can say I'm not going
to accept this that's called a fencing
token that is a term used in distributed
systems where basically you assign a
number to the current leader and that
way if an older leader tries to do
something you can say well it's got a
lower fencing token I don't care about
this and then finally the leader has an
up-to-date log and it can backfill stale
nodes so if you have a node that
basically is not completely up to date
in its log and the current leader goes
down so it's not able to basically fill
it up you know that the new leader is
going to take over and have an
up-to-date log and that way it can
actually go ahead and you know kind of
get the other nodes up to speed which is
a good thing if it is completely
possible that you would have another
node basically that is more up to date
than the leader however if that node is
more up to date than the leader it means
that that write must not have gone to a
majority of the nodes because if it had
gone to a majority of nodes then the
leader could not have been elected in
the first place recall that the leader's
log needs to be more up to date or equal
to a majority of nodes so any write that
is basically more up to date than the
leader can't be on a majority of nodes
hopefully that makes sense not that
important for the proof but interesting
stuff nonetheless so again this is a
pretty short video because mainly I want
to cover these two fundamental steps of
raft where the first one is leader elect
the second one of course is where once
we have a leader we actually start
broadcasting some rights and that's not
too complicated either but I think that
it makes a lot of sense in order to kind
of break these down into manageable
chunks because there is a lot of
thinking to be done to kind of wrap your
head around these topics and why they
actually work and Achieve consensus so
guys I hope you enjoyed the video talk
to you in the next one and have a good
rest of the weekend